a lot of people like to talk about
multivitamins and how they're an
insurance policy and it's almost
confused me as a doctor I mean you
really think there's an insurance policy
for not eating well or not exercising
and moving your body or not living in a
compassionate and peaceful way there's
there's no insurance policy for that and
you don't eat well you get sick and
that's one of the reasons that I really
promote a food first philosophy that
certainly if people have a deficiency
for example if you have an illness like
pernicious anemia where your body
doesn't allow you to absorb b12 of
course you have to take a b12 supplement
or if you're severely iron deficient
take an iron supplement but over the
long term what we really want to see is
that that people are getting their
nutrients from food so some of the
reasons for this aren't about nutrition
they're about community that when you're
engaged with your food and your food
supply when for example you go to a
farmers market or if you have kids if
you take them to a farm and teach them
about where our food comes from that
really creates a different philosophy or
different mindset about nutrition and
about how we nourish ourselves certainly
you can live on a multivitamin and you
know sipping on some coconut oil but
that to me doesn't create a great meal
and that's really where I think I think
about my favorite health delivery system
it's the it's the dinner table where as
people sit around there's a lot more
going on than just the food my family
we're talking and we're processing the
day and we're trying something new and
you've been just engaging with your food
the creative process of cooking you take
some of these wonderful foods you know
that I just picked up at the deli and
and I thought well we can just whip up a
little you know quick salad add in lots
of fats and proteins with these with
these nuts and seeds a little leafy
green with the water crest right where I
don't know I've never made a salad that
has those ingredients but it's a
creative and fun process and a way to
engage I think that's a big difference
right the idea of starting your day
taking a set of pills that someone has
prescribed for you or that we have
thought about is like that you know
that's what makes you healthy as opposed
to really seeking out the top food
sources and and that food is really the
foundation of your health there's also
some differences in terms of absorption
when you look there's some molecules for
example they just aren't in
multivitamins or aren't in as good of a
form I would say things like vitamin E
in the natural world there are eight
forms of vitamin E and supplements
there's one form in all these foods that
I love to talk about the leafy greens
and lemons and red peppers are there
there are a host of we're called
phytonutrients or plant-based nutrients
and these are really the miracle
molecules of a Y plant-based diets are
just so incredibly good for our health
because they're there signaling
molecules they literally travel from the
end of our fork into our DNA and change
how our genes get expressed and they
turn on genes that keep us healthy so so
that's another way that the supplements
and real food differ as you get these
phytonutrients I like the idea that food
becomes a way of nourishing the self in
a way that a supplement really can't
there are a lot of beliefs and
supplements but but really you can get
all the nutrients that you find in
supplements and whole good nourishing
organic foods another important
perspective when we think about brain
health is it allows us to look at
certain food trends and in certain ways
that you can take something that people
think of as healthy like juicing or a
smoothie if you look at a smoothie for a
lot of people it's often a lot of
tropical fruits and maybe some low-fat
milk or yogurt it really it's a lot of
simple sugars and we want people to have
a more robust a meal with their smoothie
so all the smoothies in eat complete
have seeds or nuts in them because I'm
trying to increase the fat content in a
smoothie and increase the protein
content now fat's been a bad word for
way too long I hope that everyone now is
considering fad as something that's
really healthy one reason is your brain
is mainly made of fat and your brain is
amazing brains human brains are amazing
so fats are very very important to brain
function and also it's important in
terms of staying full right there when
we eat fats and proteins and complex
carbohydrates our bodies just stay full
longer so you're eating fewer calories
and that helps move you towards an
optimal weight so so really eating for
brain health helps you look at something
like a smoothie and say you know I want
to get as much of the whole food as
possible so where the smoothies in our
house I don't usually juice ever in our
we just throw the whole whole food in
there whether it's kale blueberries some
kefir a little fermented dairy product
some almonds for example and blend it up
where I'm really again trying to deliver
a lot of nutrition in in a small dose
the other thing I like about smoothies
is oftentimes I'm working with patients
who are depressed and they don't have a
lot of appetite and so we know it's a
little bit of a paradox we know they
need to eat much better in terms of
really to restore their full health so
they don't have a big appetite so
something like a smoothie with again
lots of nuts and seeds and some healthy
fats really can can help them because it
goes down easy and it's in a small small
amount there are a number of myths that
I think are also really important to
dispel about eating for your health one
is the myth that it costs too much I
grew up in a food desert in Crawford
County Indiana very rural Indiana and a
food desert is a place that there isn't
fresh food and there aren't grocery
stores what's very interesting about
where I grew up is there are a lot of
farms so you'd wonder how is there a
food desert and we see what's happening
really over the last ten years in
America is a change in how we get our
food increasingly we're having food
delivered to us increasingly we're
having farms like right here in New York
City one of my favorite farms is on a
rooftop across the river a huge farm
feeds hundreds of families called
Brooklyn Grange farm so in terms of
access we really see things shifting or
there are great policies in many states
now where food stamps are two-for-one in
a farmer's market so there's this
redistribution of how we think about
food and food dollars but access can be
a huge issue so how do you find access
there are lots of great resources to
help you find local farms in your area a
CSA or Community Supported Agriculture
is a way that for a few hundred dollars
you can get a big box of produce every
single week and so there are all kinds
of little tips and hacks in terms of how
you can get this food into your diet
without spending a lot of money
eat complete is a plant-based book
plants cost less money than things like
meat and even a lot of processed foods
so when I think about how to describe
what is a healthy food to people I talk
about the rule of kale the kales have
been a phenom
and even there's a little bit of kale
backlash now but really the point is
that kale teaches us a lesson the lesson
is three lessons the rules of kale are
we want to look for foods that are
nutrient dense more nutrients per
calorie the difference between a kale
salad I've just a bevy of nutrition
right and good feeling and something
like a soda or a marshmallow right just
sugar no nutrients for your brain we
want everybody to be eating
nutrient-dense food the second rule of
kala is about culinary versatility right
that you can do a lot with it I mean you
might not think so right back in the day
kale was just in the salad bar at Pizza
Hut right there you know it's like the
third circle of hell for kale but
culinary versatility is that you can use
kale on a lot of different things you
can drop it in your smoothie you've just
increased the nutrient density of that
smoothie you can make a kale pesto or a
kale soup or a kale salad and put a nice
piece of salmon or wild shrimp on top of
it you can make a kale heat dough even
you can use it in all kinds of ways
creatively and then the third is
accessibility kale grows everywhere it's
two to three dollars for a big bunch of
organic kale you can make you know a
giant batch of kale chips you can make
off you know feed a family of four for
probably a week on a few dollars of kale
and so that's really I think we're the
accessibility issue hits home for me is
that when we forget to teach people
about proper nutrition and about our
relationship with the food supply and we
don't learn these basic culinary skills
I'm not a great chef I have a chef's
knife and my cutting board and some
olive oil and that's the base of almost
all of my dishes and a cast iron skillet
simply combining good wholesome foods
together it ends up being just
absolutely delicious and incredibly
nutritious and that's the goal and and I
think we have to really understand it's
about for a lot of people the barrier is
money in time and the money one of my
favorite little tips is around dried
beans and lentils so dried beans here in
Manhattan two dollars and twenty-nine
cents a pound for the small red bean the
small red bean has more federal treants
or antioxidants program than any other
food even more than blueberries so an
example of really really low cost point
very very nutrient
just food and then time and part of my
focus and eat complete was was trying to
find very very simple quick recipes for
people to employ in their everyday life
because as a as a clinician I really am
on the front line of seeing the
difference between sort of telling
people what to eat and helping them
really change their behavior and you
know I meet with a lot of eaters where
it's very clear to me they know exactly
what they should be eating
but how you actualize that how you
manifest that in your everyday life is
the challenge and that's where
dispelling these myths like it takes
forever I cooked breakfast for my kids
and my wife this morning in five or 10
minutes
the simple oatmeal with some almond
butter scooped on top of it if I want to
get fancy maybe I'll put a little lemon
zest on there a little cinnamon maybe
drop in some fruit simple simple Whole
Foods a real easy test of your food is
look at your plate and everything should
have one ingredient right you're looking
at Brussels sprouts maybe with a little
bacon in there or you're looking at wild
salmon with a you know a garlic scape
pesto right all things that you
recognize and know as opposed to reading
ingredients on the back of a package
where those foods are generally created
for the Shelf they're not really created
for your health